as migrants come to the United States
seeking a better life those who come
legally sometimes rely on government
benefits food and housing but that
assistance may now come at the cost of
obtaining full citizenship on Monday US
officials announced those who come to
the u.s. must be financially independent
immigrants who need help from social
programs may be denied so-called green
cards or the ability to obtain work
permits and even permanent residency
president Trump's administration is
reinforcing the ideals of
self-sufficiency and personal
responsibility ensuring that immigrants
are able to support themselves and
become successful here in America the
announcement comes just days after
officials arrested hundreds of people in
the u.s. state of Mississippi accused of
working illegally in food processing
plants the US government says it's also
targeting employers who hire such
workers but so far none of the employers
in the Mississippi raid has been fined
or arrested we just finished an
investigation very similar in Tennessee
over 150 arrests 18 months ago we now
have an individual employer who's got a
year-and-a-half sentence in federal
prison for this effort we're in the
middle of the criminal investigation in
this case we'll be pursued the raids of
sparked protests in the United States
critics say the raids are part of
president Trump's effort to marginalize
minority populations this administration
has directed DHS too to conduct these
raids as part of what I believe is this
administration's campaign of terror
which is to make holes and whole
populations of people afraid to go to
work the White House argues Congress
passed bipartisan legislation in 1996 to
prevent immigrants from exploiting
public benefits but the laws weren't
enforced as Congress has been unable to
reform immigration law the Trump
administration says it's seeking to
attract only the most self-reliant
applicants the benefit to taxpayers is a
long-term benefit of seeking to ensure
that our immigration system
is bringing people to join us as
American citizens as legal permanent
residents first who can stand on their
own two feet who will not be reliant on
the welfare system especially in the age
of the modern welfare state which is so
expansive and expensive frankly the new
immigration policy will take effect in
October but it's almost certain to face
legal challenges in the courts